the tools belong to the poor islanders
tarter Tao was current in the islands
it's just that colonialism had wiped it
out there's not anyone else here doing
traditional
the revival here started out from tattoo
machine the machine is not connected to
the old ways so I think that gap is vast
for an outsider to stand up in their app
and hold the tools up it can be
challenging I have a lung condition from
something that I'm born with it's not
something that I contracted and it's
also something that you can't catch
cystic fibrosis is the name for me it's
personally been a helping hand you know
it's been something that's I felt like
made me engage in life
you
what makes local a good student he
carries the tools well he takes
responsibility very serious
I think importance of teaching you know
and having the apprentice you know what
we do is something that's been done for
a really long time the actor now sharing
that we mogul confirms them
responsibility move the tools is an
important one because the tools the
designs they don't belong to me and it's
something that's been passed down so
it's my responsibility to ensure they're
in safe hands it's like being a
caretaker of being a caretaker or very
thin your own it's like using it with
love and passion and respect
you
ah
you